so what should the Democrats and the
Republicans negotiating about the debt
crisis do about this
they need a thoughtful bipartisan plan a
smart bipartisan plan what they should
do is agree on a temporary compromise
and then agree on bipartisan people who
are smart understand economics to work
together and in which they mutually
agree on that group of people so that
it's bipartisan because if this is not
bipartisan it's going to be a at the end
of the day it's going to be a really
problem and it's and they have to be
smart and they have to have a commission
in order to work on agree on a plan
imagine a bipartisan agreed to plan that
is smart and they have to have enough
time that maybe that's a year or two but
a bipartisan group of people who are
understand economics and engineering and
then deal with enough time to be able to
put that together is what is required